-Thank you for being here, bud.
Man, people love you.
-Good evening!
Hello, New York.
-That feels good, right?
That's got to feel good.
They love you.
We ran into each other a few
months ago at a restaurant.
-Oh, yeah.
-In L.A.
Do you remember that?
-Of course I remember that.
-Yeah, yeah. I didn't know.
I saw you.
I saw you eating.
You were with your girlfriend,
and I thought it would be funny.
I sent you over --
-An olive.
-One olive.
-I go, split it, eat it
yourself, whatever you want.
I don't want to tell you how to
eat your olive.
-Yeah, and then what did we do?
We sent you something.
-No, I'll tell you exactly
what you did.
You had the whole restaurant
come over and sing me
happy birthday.
-Oh, yes.
-And it was not my birthday.
It was not my birthday at all.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I blew out the candle.
It was not my birthday at all.
-It was not your birthday.
-It was not my birthday, but
that really made me laugh.
But then here's the best move.
You were leaving.
There was a great guy who plays
music, guitar at the --
-At the restaurant.
-We won't say where it is.
We don't want to give it away.
And so he starts singing
"Hey Jude,"
and so I jumped up
to sing with him.
-You did.
-And I thought you were gone.
-Well, no, we were still eating,
and you were still singing
"Hey Jude."
[ Laughter ]
And then they do that whole
end part, you know, where it's
just "Nah, nah, nah, nah, nah."
And you just kept going.
It was amazing.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, really.
It was high, low.
-I was harmonizing with myself.
-You were harmonizing.
-But then you --
Were you just leaving?
-Yeah, we were just leaving,
and then, you know --
-I grabbed you.
-Your energy, the whole
audience, the audience --
the restaurant was into it.
So, it was just like, let's all
sing, and we all started --
-So we sang "Hey Jude" together.
Yeah, it was fantastic.
You have a great reputation
by the way, in Hollywood
of being a very nice guy,
and I will say,
you always have been nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Always have been a cool guy
with me.
-Fix my shirt. Fix my tie.
-Yeah.
You've always been great to me.
But I saw this photo
that just -- everyone is talking
about it on the Internet.
You crashed someone's wedding
in London.
-I didn't crash --
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it looks like
you weren't invited.
I don't know.
-I sort of look like that.
-I don't know if you crashed it,
but you definitely --
-I was invited to meet
some folks and take a photo.
-Oh, sorry. So you heard people
were getting married
or something?
-No. It was outside and there
was another part of the hotel
and it was outside of London
and they were having a wedding
and then the groom came by and
he was like, "Hi,"
and I was like, "Hi."
And then he was like,
"Do you want to take a picture
with everybody?"
And I said,
"Yeah, sure, let's do it."
And meet some folks and we went
in there and I said
hi and hi and hi and then we
took some photographs.
That's one of the photographs.
-It made their night.
-One of these things
does not belong and it was me.
-I would have sang "Hey Jude"
with them if they asked me.
-It was really lovely.
-It's cool that you do
that stuff.
It's also cool that you do
this stuff too.
Can we talk about "Brzrkr"?
-Oh, you have "Brzrkr."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, I have "Brzrkr."
-It's a comic book.
-This is unbelievable.
Now, this is just an idea you
had and you go,
"I'm just going to make this."
-Yeah, I cowrote it with
Matt Kindt
and amazing illustrator
Ron Garney.
Issue 12. It's a 12-issue
limited series.
The last one came out yesterday.
-Yeah. Do you know the first --
[ Cheers and applause ]
The first issue sold over
615,000 copies, making it
the highest selling indie comic
of the 21st century.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. Thanks.
Thanks, universe.
-Wow!
-Thanks, everybody.
No, it's cool.
I love comic books, and having
the chance to do something
like that was really special.
-How did you end up coming up
with a storyline and everything?
-Where do ideas come from?
-I know, yeah,
that's a very deep question.
-Where do they --
it came to me -- What about
a character that could punch
people through the chest?
And then, like, what if they
were half God, half immortal?
And then what if they were alive
for 80,000 years?
-What would you do
with this idea --
-Then what would society do
with that
but then he's cursed with
violence.
-He doesn't want to be violent.
-No, but it's in his blood.
-He can't die.
Then he doesn't know
who his father is.
-Are you kidding me?
-There's this tribe that
asks the gods for a weapon
because they're being ambushed
and exploited every season.
And then they get this kid --
-When are we seeing this movie?
I want to see this! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, and then he's, like,
being used by
the United States government.
They're trying to figure him
out.
-Of course the government gets
involved. Yes.
-Yes. Black ops.
-But what would you do with
this idea, Keanu Reeves, if you
couldn't have this outlet?
Would this just live
in your brain?
[ Laughter ]
I don't know. You did it.
-I don't know.
-You got it out.
I mean, it's like
a creative act.
It's something special.
-It is, yeah.
-It's storytelling.
And what would I do
if I couldn't do that?
I'd probably be on
the street, just babbling.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Would you make this
into a movie?
-Yeah, that would be fun.
-Yeah. Would you direct it?
-Mm. I don't know. I don't know.
We tried to shop it around,
and then Netflix said,
"Hey, do you want to make it
with us?"
And I was like, "Sure."
And then so we're going to try
and make that happen.
-Whoa!
I love it.
We have to talk about
"John Wick: Chapter 4."
Buddy, you did it again.
It's unbelievable!
It's -- This one --
This one's the best.
-What?
-This one is the best one.
Yes.
-The best? What?
-Plug your ears because I know
they're all your babies.
But I like this one.
-What? That's awesome.
-The first one was like,
"Holy moly."
-I know, what the heck is that?
-I loved it. I didn't know
the first one was even out.
I don't know how I even saw
the first one.
And I go, "Oh, my gosh." I think
I was in a hotel somewhere.
I go, "This movie is
phenomenal."
I call my wife, I go, "You've
got to watch 'John Wick.'"
I'm in all the way man,
and we love you,
and the whole Fallons love
the Keanu at the house.
Well, you celebrate my birthday
when it's not my birthday.
It's great.
This one has got it all.
It looks gorgeous.
It's a work of art.
The action starts maybe
five seconds into it
and doesn't stop until you leave
the theater.
-Yeah, there's a lot of action.
-You're on a horse at one point.
-Yeah.
-Shooting people.
-Well, you know, I'm -- Yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
There's nunchucks.
-Yes, there are.
-Yeah.
There's throwing stars.
-There's --
-Driving. Crazy driving.
-By the way, driving scenes
with no doors.
-Yeah, yeah.
-No windows maybe at one point.
-They got blown out too.
-There's just a steering wheel
and wheels, that's all it is.
It's like a go-cart at the end
of it.
-It's an American muscle car.
And throwing 180s.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Doing John Wick things.
-I read somewhere there's
14 action sequences.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-And it's all choreographed
brilliantly.
-Yeah, most of the time.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's always --
Well, I can't say always.
-Is there improvising ever?
-Yeah, kind of, yeah.
-And does that end well?
No?
-Yes.
No humans were harmed in
the making of this film.
-Thank you, yeah.
-No, I mean, there's a lot --
the director, visionary Chad
Stahelski, is very inventive.
He really wants to create
different kinds of environments
or ways in the storytelling
for the action.
-He's got to be a genius.
I mean, this is the fourth one.
You're still inventing new ways
to go,
"Oh, that shot is gorgeous.
How did he even come up
with that?"
The cars on the side, the lights
hitting you at a certain thing.
-Cinema.
-It feels like cinema.
-It feels like you're
watching -- Yes!
-Cinema.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What can we say about
"John Wick" and this one
that's not spoiling anything?
Or can I just -- I know you want
to get out, like always.
You don't want to do this.
-I don't.
I'm looking for
my personal freedom.
-Yes.
-You know?
It starts with trying to get
my ring back,
but that doesn't work so well.
-No.
-I get a little angry.
But then I'm looking for
my personal freedom.
There's a whole bunch of
new characters
who are opening up the world
of the High Table.
-Who plays Caine?
-Caine is Donnie Yen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's a legend.
Hiroyuki Sanada, Rina Sawayama,
who was on your show.
-Rina Sawayama is fantastic.
She was on last night.
-She's awesome.
-It's a crusher cast.
-Shamier Anderson.
So we have The Tracker.
We have Caine, we have Shimazu,
so all of these
different characters.
It's friendship, brotherhood,
father, daughter,
the choices you make, rules and
consequences, who are you, man?
-Wow! Come on!
-Who are we?
-Whoo!
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Keanu Reeves
in "John Wick: Chapter 4."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-John?
-Caine.
They gave you my name.
-Yeah.
-I'm sorry.
-Me too.
-No, no, no! Come on! Cinema!
Keanu Reeves,
"John Wick: Chapter 4" is
in theaters and IMAX March 24th.
Keanu and I are playing
"Pup Quiz" after the break.
Come on back.